y a continuación va a pasar aquí al
estudio nuestra compañera responsable de
las emisiones de cultura que en France
24 lea urel para acercarnos un poco a
todos estos elementos que nos acercan
también valga la redundancia a la
familia real británica lea bienvenida
Buenos días Hola alea bienvenida Rosa
pues por dónde quiere empezar Rosa
hablando entonces de Este descubrimiento
especial hablamos Entonces pues no
nos quiere hacer algunas recomendaciones
precisamente lea que nos acerquen a esto
a la familia real Sí Rosa Tienes razón
pero primero si ciertos televidentes se
preguntan si voy a hablar del fenómeno
La respuesta es obviamente es la serie
que fascina tanto al público como la
crítica desde hace unos años y que con
su mezcla de ficción y de
acontecimientos reales sirve la imagen
de la corona británica a la vez que la
Pero antes de eso si me lo permiten
vamos a mirar de lado de los libros y de
las películas que también alimentaron y
siguen alimentando la fascinación o el
odio hacia estos Reyes y príncipes de
los tiempos modernos todas esas obras no
son recomendaciones sino que según los
enfoques reflejan las preguntas que se
hace el público y el material que
inspira a los artistas empezamos
entonces con literatura Sí exactamente
la realiza británica constituye
obviamente un tema de investigación
histórica lo hemos visto con nuestro
compañero Álvaro por su poder político
diplomático y su larga existencia
entonces existen muchos libros de
carácter histórico o biografías que
cuentan Cómo funciona la corona y
quiénes son todos todos esos personajes
atrás vemos un par de libros por ejemplo
tenemos unos más clásicos como los once
miembros de la familia real británica o
la entonces Esas obras que explican un
poquito que cuentan todo alrededor de de
la realeza muchas biografías que
retratan una persona específica y que
intentan Mostrar el ser humano detrás
del título real para hablar de sus
emociones de sus éxitos y de sus
derrotas de sus secretos también hay El
ejemplo de El rey la vida de Carlos
tercero de periodista estadounidense
Christopher andersen y además es la
primera biografía a salir después de la
muerte de la reina también tenemos a
Lady in Waiting mi extraordinaria vida a
la sombra de la corona escrito por Ana
lincolner Aquí fue la dama de honor de
la princesa Margarita pero existen
también biografías un poco más del lado
de los escándalos Obviamente que cuentan
y que quieren provocar con todos esos
escándalos tenemos a Diana Diana su
verdadera historia justo acá del
periodista
morton que un libro que fue agotado un
día después de su publicación en 1992 Y
tuvo un impacto muy fuerte en esta época
por las cosas que que revelaba también
tenemos a papers de Diana Brown o Spear
en la sombra del príncipe el hijo de
Lady di y el Rey Carlos pero también
tenemos algunos libros de ficción como
este libro acá abajo el nudo winstore la
primera novela de la serie de sj bennet
que pone a la Reina Isabel segunda a
investigar misteriosos crímenes la Reina
Isabel dio para toda esta para un
personaje de ficción basado en ella
misma hablemos ahora de las películas
películas que cuentan historias basadas
en hechos de la historia de la familia
real británica Sí Santiago podemos
destacar tres películas en particular
que tratan de tres épocas diferentes de
la corona británica Victoria y Abdul el
discurso del rey y
primero Victoria y Abdul dirigida por
stephens cuenta la historia real de la
amistad entre la reina Victoria y su
sirviente indio abdulkarima a finales
del siglo XIX cuando el discurso del rey
de Tom hooper revela otra amistad la de
Jorge Vito sexto con el padre de Isabel
con su fonoaudiólogo australiano y cómo
trabajaron juntos para vencer la
tartamudez del rey pero la película La
más emblemática yo creo es
también la actriz fue aplaudida por su
interpretación de Isabel II y además en
2006 su estreno marcó un punto de
inflexión en cuanto a la imagen de la
monarca por aparecer una figura más
accesible más emocional más emotiva es
la película que más se acerca además a
los personajes que conocemos todos y
todas hoy en día Además del inexistente
obviamente muchos mentales sobre Isabel
segunda su reino Las joyas de la de la
corona británica y también yo quería
mencionar la serie la recién serie
documental Harry y Megan en la
plataforma de streaming Netflix es lo
que es pero permite entender la presión
mediática alrededor de las mujeres que
entran en esta familia Real Como fue el
caso de Meghan markle la esposa del
príncipe Harry y siempre me parece
bastante interesante Escuchar como los
mismos protagonistas cuentan su versión
de estas trayectorias fuera de lo común
lea y lo prometió al principio de esta
Crónica no puede irse sin hablar de The
Crown obviamente rosa es que la muy
exitosa serie dramática
cuyas cinco temporadas están disponibles
en la plataforma de streaming Netflix se
convirtió en la obra imprescindible en
cuanto a la familia real británica esta
serie fue aclamada por su elenco que que
cambia entre casi cada temporada para
seguir El paso del tiempo Obviamente si
miramos al personaje de Carlos tercero
Josh lo interpretó durante las
temporadas 3 y 4 y es Dominic West quien
retomó el papel en la temporada 5
temporada 5 en la temporada muy
importante para the Crown que sirve de
introducción a la que sin duda será la
más difícil para el nuevo rey la sexta y
última temporada que se centrará en la
muerte de Diana y en su campaña para que
Camila sea etcétera como reina consorte
desde que empezó la difusión de la serie
la monarquía la considera peligrosa para
la imagen de sus miembros y sobre todo
la imagen de Carlos que se ve
maquiavélico cruel con Diana manipulador
y odioso de hecho todas las obras que
cuentan la relación entre Carlos y entre
Diana suelen retratar al nuevo rey como
el culpable de su fracasado
de junio con Lady di muestran también
que la figura de Diana sigue inspirando
a los artistas es el caso de la película
Spencer del director chileno Pablo
larain y del guionista británico Steven
night una película que se puede ver en
Amazon Prime video y que pretende situar
el espectador en el estado de su heroína
y sus problemas de Salud Mental durante
una inquietante Navidad a principios de
los años 90 para explicar cómo las cosas
empezaron a desintegrarse entonces va a
ser interesante seguir analizando como
las obras
influencian a la opinión pública por lo
que aunque el índice de popularidad de
carllus tercero ha subido desde la
muerte de su madre sigue siendo bastante
frágil Muchas gracias elea por este
completo reporte de este panorama
general de lo que significa a nivel
cultural la familia real británica